[Applauso]
[Musica]
Buonasera
pipistrelli creature della notte cosa
sapete voi dei pipistrelli Quali sono i
miti le leggende legate a questi animali
che conoscete
si attaccano ai capelli succhiano il
sangue
sono cattivi sono pericolosi
allora questa sera anche dato
l'argomento della serata voglio fare con
voi un esperimento una prova di coraggio
voglio portarvi nel regno di queste
creature della notte per imparare magari
a conoscere meglio e perché no anche
apprezzarle un po' di più
Innanzitutto anche se
esistono al mondo delle specie di grande
dimensioni
le specie italiane europee sono specie
di piccole dimensioni alle mie spalle il
primo incontro ravvicinato con questi
animali potete vedere un adulto di una
delle specie che si trovano più spesso
vicino alle nostre case che volano
intorno ai lampioni e qualche volta
entrano pure in casa
sicuramente il romanzo più iconico
legato a questi animali è Dracula di
Bram Stoker romanzo che tra l'altro
l'attore l'autore scrisse dopo
un'indigestione di gamberetti
Pensate se avesse scritto di un conte
che si trasformava in un gamberone la
vita dei pipistrelli sarebbe stata molto
più facile Però certamente
nell'immaginario nell'immaginario
nell'iconografia le ali di un diavolo
sono le ali di un pipistrello mentre le
ali di un angelo sono le ali di un
uccello però
però se noi osserviamo da vicino l'ala
di un pipistrello ci accorgiamo che in
realtà è una vera e propria mano Alata
Infatti il nome scientifico dei
pipistrelli chirotteri significa proprio
mano Alata E questo perché sono gli
unici mammiferi Quindi come noi in grado
di volo attivo quindi se ci pensiamo
bene se noi avessimo le ali sarebbero
Certamente delle ali da pipistrello e
non delle ali da uccello
si attaccano i capelli Quanti di voi
hanno sentito che si attaccano i capelli
e
a quanti di voi è veramente successo in
prima persona Io credo che nessuno sia
successo in questa sala e questa è una
delle credenze più diffuse legate ai
pipistrelli e più falsa come me
tantissimi ricercatori ogni anno hanno
entrano per motivi di studio di ricerca
nei siti di rifugio delle colonie quale
mie spalle vedete una colonia di
pipistrelli di femmine che ogni
primavera si trovano insieme in
centinaia e migliaia di esemplari per
dare alla luce piccoli e non mi è mai
successo di avere un pipistrello
attaccato ai capelli Ho il cappellino
perché sotto una colonia di pipistrelli
cade davvero di tutto
tratti con le ali in tutti i dialetti si
parla di ratavulon Ratti che volano la
genetica ha dimostrato che non c'è
niente di più vero di più falso i
pipistrelli non sono Ratti con le ali
sono molto più vicini ai cani e gatti
addirittura i delfini che i topi sono
animali molto intelligenti vivono fino a
40 anni e assolutamente sono quanto di
più lontano ci sia da un topo
non sono ciechi ma preferiscono
orientarsi tramite quella che si chiama
Eco localizzazione
emettono ultrasuoni suoni che noi umani
non riusciamo a sentire e con questi si
orientano nello spazio grazie a una vera
e propria visione uditiva
E pensate che proprio lo studio di
queste proprietà dei pipistrelli ci ha
permesso di sviluppare quelle che sono
alcune delle moderne tecnologie Pensiamo
ad esempio e sonaro e biostensori ed è
anche il motivo per cui se un
pipistrello entra in casa vostra Non
dovete assolutamente urlare e disturbare
questo meccanismo è molto meglio stare
in silenzio
respirare come diceva Lucilla La prima
aprire la finestra e vedrete che i
pipistrelli usciranno da soli
sono pericolosi Allora qua alle mie
spalle vedete la classifica degli
animali più pericolosi al mondo incluse
le zanzare e pensavo le zanzare la
malaria e i pipistrelli non sono nemmeno
in questa lista però se pensiamo alla
dieta di pipistrelli che di zanzare si
nutrono i notevoli quantità addirittura
pipistrelli possono essere una soluzione
al problema
trasmettono i virus i pipistrelli sono
fauna selvatica e come tale ospitano dei
virus a potenziale zoonotico ma non sono
diversi da altri ordini di mammiferi o
uccelli semplicemente il numero di virus
è proporzionale al numero di Specie per
ciascun ordine
trasmettono il coronavirus
è vero a mille chilometri da One è stato
trovato un pipistrello che aspettava che
ospitava un virus in qualche modo simile
a quello che ha dato inizio alla nostra
pandemia ma questo virus non era in
grado di infettare l'uomo un virus
Invece meno simile ma con questa
potenzialità è stato trovato nel
pangolino e sco coronavirus che possono
infettare l'uomo sono stati ritrovati in
altri animali in particolar modo
nell'ordine dei carnivori
Forse noi non sappiamo ancora
cosa è stato a dare origine alla
pandemia e Qualcuno dice che non lo
sapremo mai quello che però è vero e sei
stato reale è stato l'accanimento
scientifico e mediatico contro i
pipistrelli considerati colpevoli Fino a
prova contraria di aver dato inizio alla
pandemia e questo nonostante nessun
rischio sanitario ci sia per vicinanza a
delle colonie di pipistrelli per la
trasmissione di Sars covid-19 come
ribadito dall'ispra e questo
nonostante non ci fosse nessuna prova
scientifica che indicasse che questa via
era quella da seguire per la ricerca
scientifica semplicemente abbiamo visto
i pipistrelli si trovano in rifugi Per
cui possiamo campionare centinaia o
migliaia di esemplari con uno sforzo
molto piccolo e soprattutto ai
pipistrelli nell'immaginario sono degli
animali spaventosi e quindi rispondevano
bene all'esigenza di un capro espiatorio
per una situazione come quella della
pandemia drammatica Nessuno lo mette in
discussione
quello che possiamo fare per prevenire
le future pandemie Io penso che sia
questo le zone incontaminate del mondo
dovrebbero rimanere tali e l'uomo non
dovrebbe metterci piede se non per
motivi di studio di ricerca ma in tutto
il resto del mondo Io penso che quello
che dobbiamo fare non è separare l'uomo
dalla natura ma cercare di realizzare la
miglior coesistenza possibile nel
rispetto dell'ambiente
sicuramente questo è un discorso che
potrebbe andare avanti ore molto
complicato per cui per stasera finiamo
qua e vi racconto un altro mito legato
ai pipistrelli
succhiano il sangue ci sono tre specie
in Sudamerica che succhiano sangue
animale e in particolar modo bovino
mentre tutte le specie italiane e
europee sono pipistrelli che si nutrono
principalmente di ragni e insetti e
pensate
che sono veramente straordinari da
questo punto di vista perché non solo si
nutrono di insetti fastidiosi come le
zanzare ma anche di insetti dannosi come
quelli che danneggiano le nostre
coltivazioni
pensate che nei soli Stati Uniti i
pipistrelli fanno risparmiare agli
agricoltori 23 miliardi di dollari
l'anno solo in trattamenti fitosanitari
risparmiati e questo nei soli Stati
Uniti Infatti i pipistrelli sono
importantissimi providers di quello che
si chiamano servizi ecosistemici cioè
che benefici multipli che l'ambiente ci
dà titolo gratuito e che permette la
nostra sopravvivenza sulla terra non
solo
predano insetti fastidiosi o dannosi ma
in tante parti del mondo si nutrono
anche di frutta e quindi contribuiscono
la dispersione dei semi di piante ad
interesse alimentare e anche
contribuiscono all'impollinazione di
queste piante
l'uomo quindi ha tantissimo da
guadagnare dai pipistrelli e poco da
perdere non è invece vero il contrario
tutte le specie italiane e europee sono
protette Perché molte specie sono
minacciate del rischio di estinzione
pensate che in Italia i pipistrelli sono
protetti dal 1939 Perché addirittura il
re aveva capito la loro importanza nella
lotta alla malaria e perché sono
minacciate
Innanzitutto dall'avvento dei pesticidi
proprio vediamo dall'avvento del diretti
c'è stato un crollo terrificante della
consistenza delle popolazioni di
pipistrelli e questi questi pesticidi
questi fitofarmaci non sono solo un
problema ambientale per le specie
selvatiche non Ma sono anche un problema
sanitario
per la distruzione o l'alterazione degli
Habitat che stanno diventando dei
deserti in cui le specie selvatiche non
possono più sopravvivere e non solo
rifugi naturali ma anche rifugi
artificiali come ad esempio le chiese
gli edifici storici in cui Questi
animali si trovavano rifugio e adesso
non possono più rifugiarsi Perché
vengono illuminate per motivi artistici
a causa della scorretta progettazione
degli impianti eolici che sono delle
tecnologie Green Ma se non progettate
correttamente sono un problema non solo
per i pipistrelli ma per tutta la fauna
migratrice
sono minacciati dall'inquinamento
luminoso questa foto viene spesso
utilizzata a livello europeo per
promuovere il nostro paese in modo quasi
romantico in realtà è una foto
drammatica che ci mostra come l'Italia
sia uno dei paesi del G20 che risente
maggiormente dell'inquinamento luminoso
cosa l'inquinamento luminoso e quella
alterazione del buio naturale che non
solo non ci permette di vedere le stelle
noi abbiamo il diritto di vedere le
stelle ma è anche un problema per tutte
quelle specie che migrano cercando di
orientarsi con le stelle ed è anche un
problema per la nostra salute
e infine sono minacciati
dall'ignoranza e dal vandalismo in
particolare a seguito della pandemia
abbiamo avuto degli episodi drammatici
di distruzione di intere colonie per
paura
questo signore ha le mie spalle Merle in
tattole fondatore di watt conservation
International
tuttle insieme a tante ricercatori al
mondo Me compresa è convinta che
l'accanimento scientifico è mediatico
contro i pipistrelli non contribuirà a
salvarci dalla prossima pandemia ma
certamente contribuirà alla distruzione
di qualsiasi sforzo di conservazione
fatto finora per aiutare questi animali
Cosa possiamo fare noi nel nostro
piccolo per aiutarli Sicuramente io
spero anche grazie alla a questa serata
cercare di condividere delle
informazioni più positive rispetto a
questi animali cercare di convincere le
altre persone delle loro importanza per
il mantenimento degli equilibri degli
ecosistemi e quindi per la nostra
sopravvivenza sulla terra ma anche senza
un fine utilitaristico io sono convinta
che la conservazione della biodiversità
sia un diritto e un valore per cui noi
dobbiamo combattere per la nostra e per
le future generazioni Buonanotte
[Applauso]